hallo leute wie sieht eure mal waren und
willkommen zu einem neuen test video und
heute werden wir wie im titel gelesen
habt ja nun an
nanu nana produkte testen auch wenn
beinahe hauptsächlich saisonaler träsch
verkauft wird bin ich ein großer fan
denn man findet dort dann doch immer
wieder die eine oder andere sache die
das geschenk noch auf ein neues level
bringt den letzten schliff verpasst die
kirche auf dem eis besser platziert
airways eine sache habe ich allerdings
auf nanu nana beinahe nur noch nie
probiert und zwar deren süßigkeiten
scherzartikel süßigkeiten aber ich lasse
mich heute überraschen wir testen uns
mal durch und starten jetzt mit dem
video okay wir starten jud süß mit dem
ersten produkt you let my heart popcorn
flavoured marshmallow sieht süß aus mit
der verpackung ist es hier einmal
aufmachen
[Applaus]
in der packung fünf glocken
man bekommt dieses popcorn übrigens für
195 jetzt der staub rauch zieht ganz
richtig und süß aus hoffe ihr könnt
sehen
doch kommen wir zum tales test sind
stabile marshmallows hätte ich niemals
gekauft außer für den test aber falls im
marshmallow freunde ja erst mal wieder
den mund reinigen machen wir weiter mit
den süßen liebes sachen hier das ist
doch süß älter ist jung nur besser
1 euro 50 für 30 gramm bekommt eine
standard kleine tafel schokolade ist ja
süß
zuerst hat man das gefühl man ist zu
einem all die schoko weihnachtsmann aber
es schmeckt ganz gut also es ist nicht
eklig oder so und es ist sogar eine uns
und zertifizierte schokolade kommen wir
zum nächsten produkt ich glaube dieses
produkt hat schon jeder mal in so einem
laden gesehen eine unnötig lange
marshmallow stangl es sah so bescheuert
aus als ich auf meinem fahrrad saß und
mit einer hand diese stange festgehalten
habe
aber not gonna live die marshmallows
sehen wirklich in der liebes aus für
fünf euro kann es auch du diese stange
erwerben sieht ganz unschuldig aus wie
ein marshmallow ist aber kein
marshmallow das ist eine schau
zuckerwatte großer unterschied mehr lohn
geschmack dann haben wir hier noch so
wirkliche marshmallows dran kleben gehe
ich mit marshmallow auch mit meinem
geschmack
ja ist okay leute ist ist okay lasst uns
das nächste produkt benutzen verwenden
testen lasst uns das nächste produkt
testen unser nächstes produkt ist etwas
das ich tatsächlich aus meiner kindheit
kenne und zwar immer wenn ich nach polen
gefahren bin habe ich die bekommen den
handarbeit hergestellte lollis mit
diesen iconic mussten drauf es gibt
sogar auf youtube so viele videos wo sie
zeigen wie sie diese zuckermasse
ineinander verrühren und dann irgendwie
noch eine schicht und dann noch eine
farbschicht das dann so krass zu einfach
so einem strang machen ist trocknen
lassen und dann packen die das so ab und
dann siehst du erst so das muster was
sich dahinter versteckt und das ist hier
genauso in dinkelsbühl foyer schmeckt
nach muffigen zucker es so richtig
lecker so bleiben wir mal bei dem
zuckerwaren unter nächstes produkt ist
mini candy pizza 82 eur 590 kriegt man
das kennt ihr höchstwahrscheinlich es
ist eine gummi pizza sie auch einfach
doppelt in plastik verpackt ist wie
kommt schon wieder dieser qualitativen
nicht hochwertige gummigeruch entgegen
ja leider habe ich mir auch nichts
besseres vorstellen
ja sie die aus meines ist eine ganze
vincent de also soll eine pizza
darstellen hier so der pizza ganz da
haben wir die
salami und das ei und tomatensoße und
auf der pizza gibt es noch extra kleine
pizzastücke denn wer ist nicht am
liebsten pizza mit pizza und ob
[Musik]
probieren wir mal so eine banane ja brav
ist es ganz stabil als kind hat es gerne
gegessen sieht aus wie eine pizza komme
ich finde es gibt auch bessere
süßigkeiten aber für drei euro ist ein
süßes geschenk kommen wir zum nächsten
und zwar einen supersüßen für 50 cent
teuren glückskeks die bekommt man
eigentlich in chinesischen oder
asiatischen läden nach dem essen aber
das design ist wirklich absolut dann
lasst uns mal schauen wie meine zukunft
aussieht hilfe ich bin einer keksfabrik
gefangen man ist nie zu alt zum lernen
worauf französische beruhigt eu
kontrolleuren komisch mit einem
glückskeks kann man auch irgendwie
nichts falsch machen
noch immer kommen wir nun zu der
kategorie die ich in einer am meisten
gefeiert habe das ist so ein richtiger
ahlmann humor also glaube mehr eimern
humor gibt es nicht wirklich sie haben
eine wand die aussieht als ob sie eine
apotheke stehen könnte und dort haben
wir produkte wie schleck impfung stoppt
den stress sorgt für entspannung und
gibt neue energie
er sieht aus wie man so richtig so einem
film einfach so ein kind lolli gibt
[Musik]
oh mein gott ich habe den lonnie mund
genommen und habe mich entspannt nach
hinten gelehnt wirkt der schmeckt auch
simpel und nach zugang
aber er hat zu diesem gewissen meinen
stress habe ich besiegt aber jetzt
brauche ich auch noch notfall schokolade
im notfall die scheibe einschlagen macht
die dose bis die was kann wenn man jetzt
[Musik]
die sieht ja richtig süß aussieht so
richtig aus wie man sich so eine kleine
geladen habe vorstellt was labert ist
schon wieder fast 1100 all die schoko
weihnachtsmann main kostet zwei euro 95
das ist keine 295 schublade so bei
dieser medizin die jetzt in ihrer hand
halte wird sich kelly sehr freuen denn
das würde sie mir auf verschreiben
klugscheißer ritus pille bei penetranter
besserwisserei gut verträglich schnell
wirksam was ist das überhaupt
vier euro ihr müsst euch merken 404 euro
4 euro 4 euro
wenn die jetzt nicht wie die besten
schokolinsen aller zeigen schmecken
kommt heute 11 4 euro dafür dass ihr
euch eine lustige verpackung ausgedacht
haben das haben die liste kostet drei
euro
naja gut drei leute ist ein euro pro
link sowie medizin hat aber natürlich
noch andere mittel die will ich jetzt
schutzimpfung aber gegen liebeskummer
morgens mittags abends führt
möglicherweise zu krassen partyexzessen
was die uns eigentlich damit sagen
möchten hast du liebeskummer kauf dir
einen rein fünf euro
von wegen drei schnäpse tür so aber ich
liebeskummer an timo
[Musik]
eine schmeckt also dass irgendjemand in
seinem keller selber zusammengebraut hat
es ist wirklich das alltäglichste was
ich jemals getrunken haben
lebt weiter rezept nervennahrung vier
euro für ein schnaps beruhigungsmittel
willkommen in deutschland wo schnaps als
beruhigungsmittel verkauft wird aber ich
bin jetzt mal nicht so ein spiel seine
somit die cd zum teil zeigt tag die
wohnen ja okay wir haben damit eine
gruppe h okay das handy auch irgendwie
cool wieder
es hat sich nämlich herausgestellt meine
damen und herren dass das gleichzeitig
eine grußkarte ist wow nächste medizin
sei frech serum auch für drei euro pro
monat sei frech währung klingt auch so
ein bisschen und die verpackung sieht
auch aus als ob es von harry potter sein
könnte wenn das letztlich wegen guter
fisch schmeckt ist nicht so meins zwar
bleiben wir doch einfach mal beim thema
alkohol
denn das lieben wir allermeisten ich gab
konnte einfach nicht widerstehen
ein glas das gefüllt ist mit weingummi
und es sieht aus wie bier fünf euro 95
guck doch immer den unterschied an
was sind das für preise ich hab das
gefühl so irgendjemand klebte einfach
irgendwelche preise drauf das konnte man
beim kaufen gar nicht lesen best friends
forever keine dicke marshmallows
schmeckt noch marshmallow vor wenn das
jetzt nach bier schmecken würde dass wir
fanden
[Musik]
zitrone aber warum macht man denn nicht
man könnte doch das bein gummi gibt
geschmack mäßig machen es wäre doch das
marshmallow schmeckbar bierschaum unser
letztes produkt finde ich passt einfach
perfekt zu gerade einfach die beste zeit
ist jetzt wären perlwein halbtrocken
sotiris leute auf eine gute zeit auch
eine verrückte zeit post ja das schmeckt
ganz fantastisch falls ihr eine bff habt
dann schenkt ihr zu dem bierglas doch
gleich den bären perlwein einkauf dem
verkauf der marke die sie mag und clip
so das war mein großer test von
getränken und lebensmitteln und
süßigkeiten aus langerringen dich noch
nie probiert habt so wie marshmallows
und smarties
ich meine natürlich klugscheißer pilger
beim nächsten mal wieder schreib doch
mal was empfiehlt ihr denn soweit nun
danach hat für meine kommentare bis dann